I think I need help with my laundry.
Hello washed and left out to dry, Trace here
rockin' new duds on DNews.
You might think science is something only
done in labs, but every week-or-so chances
are you suspend organic and synthetic fibers
in a solution of water, enzymes, surfactants,
and detergents to confine particulates and
relax molecular bonds.
In layman's terms: you do laundry, and when
you think about it, it really is like controlled
chemistry!
Unfortunately, we don't all do this at-home
science in the same way, which is why when
doing laundry, we've all messed up a favorite
sweater or shrunk a pair of [pants?] but why
do these things shrink at all?!
What's going on there?
So, firstly, there are a couple kinds of fibers
used to make clothing: synthetic and natural.
In general, synthetics are man-made polymers
like polyester, rayon, Kevlar, or acrylic.
Their fibers are strings of petroleum-based
chemical chains.
Synthetics made from petroleum products don't
typically shrink in laundry because the washer
and dryer do not get hot enough to mess with
their structure.
So, let's ignore those.
Natural fibers, on the other hand, come from
animals and plants.
The fibers of cotton, wool or silk are naturally
curly and tangled.
When you want to weave these threads into
fabrics, you have to stretch and pull them
to make them straight.
But if given the opportunity to return to
their natural curly state they will.
And scientists have discovered the heat and
mechanical energy in laundry machines let
them do just that -- in a process called shrinkage.
There are three kinds of shrinkage: Relaxation,
Felting, and Consolidation.
Relaxing is the immediate release of that
stretching and pulling tension left behind
from the straightening of the natural fibers.
That tension exists on a molecular level,
and is leftover from the manufacturing process.
When tepid or warm water is added to the natural
fabric, the warmth will let the fabric swell,
reducing the size by about 1 percent.
Not too shabby.
Felting shrinkage is when the fibers themselves
actually get shorter.
If you magnify wool in an electron microscope
it's made of tiny scales, just like human
hair.
According to a paper in the Textile Research
Journal, the heat from the washer can expand
these scales letting water get between them.
Water is slippery, so it reduces the coefficient
of friction, and those scales slide together,
contracting rootward, like a retracting car
or radio antenna!
The third type is Consolidation shrinkage,
and it happens in the laundry process itself.
The mechanical bouncing action of your washer
and drier beats up the fibers, curling them
back up again.
A 2002 study in The Research Journal of Association
of Universities for Textiles.
found the structure of the fabric affects
shrinkage too.
Denim jeans are tightly-woven cotton so they
only shrink a little, but sweaters are mostly
air!
So they can shrink as much as 30 percent according
to Popular Science.
Even the natural moisture content of the fibers
themselves can affect shrinkage: cotton has
about 5 percent, wool has about 17 percent,
so over-drying can will inevitably cause clothing
to change shape.
In World War II, Nazi scientists added plastics
to wool to fill in the spaces and solidify
the fibers, sometimes, and today this continues
with manufacturers weaving in non-shrinking
synthetics, and chemists inventing new anti-shrinking
agents to cover natural fibers and keep them
from curling up.
Look, scientists who did write papers on shrinkage
were quick to point out: everyone does laundry
differently.
Water temperature, amount of time, detergent,
clothing fibers, and even machine manufacturer
all add variables to to the at-home science
project that is laundry.
The best way to love your clothes is to remember:
one: follow the instructions on the tag because
the people who made it know what's in there
and how to clean it, but when in doubt don't
add heat and mechanical energy.
Use cold water and avoid the dryer.
And two: remember that natural fiber clothing
is made from the parts of living things!
Living things aren't supposed to last forever.
And that's okay.
We'd like to take a second and thank our sponsor
for this episode: AT and T. AT&T Digital Life
smart home security helps keep you connected
to your home, so there are no more what ifs.
Skinny jeans, sweaters, tiny t-shirts… why
am I reminded of hipsters?
Oh, because they're all the same!
At least, that's what this mathematician discovered!
I did a whole video about it here, so grab
your fancy coffee and give it a click.
Do you love laundry?
Hate it?
Super meticulous about it?